tu as vu le match hier soir la télé
alors j'ai pas les chaînes payantes
tu as joué te dire à payer pour voir
jouer des chefs t'as raison
non je me suis vu un film je me suis
régalé je sais plus petit at on commencé
c'est quoi l'histoire parce que des fois
avec l'histoire on peut retrouver le
titre man histoire cette dernière ya
celui qui fait les pubs des capsules de
café tu sais d'un smic et bauer oui tu
le connais de lui aux ja lui il ya il ya
eu une comédienne tu la connais aussi
les connu et c'est sandra bullock est
malheureux que je sais pas
et donc ils sont un espace cd mécano tu
sais il est par les satellites efforts
pour télévision tout ça ils sont bien
sommet d'un coup houston les appels aux
dégâts attention aux liens satellites il
a explosé il ya tous les débris viennent
sur vous à fond il faut partir de là ce
cap et quand tu es obligé de te pas
bougé dans l'espace ils essayent comme
ça nous arrive au pas avancer alors il
ya celui des capsules lui il avait la
machine par tous comme ça il part il
tombe en panne d'essence on ne trouvait
plus ce complice et personne ne les
autres ce qu'on connaît pas qu'on s'en
fout il crève bon on s'en fout et après
il reste sandra bullock là et elle n
avait un cordon qui tenait à la navette
le cordon il se coupe
elle paraissait pas pouvoir être trouvés
l'inspecteur un inspecteur s'en sort
grâce instructeur deux coups
destructeurs qui qui est troublant un
satellite chinois y avait les clés
dessus
elle rentre avec notamment un suspense
non
gr métier quand vous avez dit c'est
gravity le film comme voilà c'est ça
franchement on n'est pas bien oui c'est
bien je suis rigoni